foreign
[Music]
there it is the photo opportunity and
the signing of the documents President
Putin has just signed documents to
incorporate territories off Ukraine into
the Russian Federation in this televised
ceremony so once again he signed the
treaties alongside the Moscow appointed
authorities in the four regions of
lugansk Donetsk zaparita and her son
they've just signed the treaties and
President Putin has effectively absorbed
these Ukrainian regions into the Russian
Federation let's once again bring in
Patrick burry he's the defense and
security Analyst at the University of
bath joining us again from Bath in the
United Kingdom so Patrick burry we were
just witnessing the signing ceremony and
before we broke away you were saying
that while Putin was speaking there was
nothing really threatening in what he
had to say but from a security point of
view he he did say that we will work to
increase Security in the is new four
regions how what do you read into that
statement what does he mean by that yeah
during it just to clarify what I was
saying was that you know in terms of
what he the threats and uh that he'd
made before regarding these territories
and them coming under Russia's
um nuclear umbrella there was nothing
new in terms of there was no ultimatum
to Ukraine for example to stop attacking
them um as far as we know from the
translation we've just had
um there was no telling Ukraine to get
out of these oblast their Armed Forces
he did refer to them as terrorists and
Rebels mind you so
um the security implications now are you
know what does Ukraine do in these
oblasts do they keep attacking and then
and I'd imagine they will in the short
term uh and how does Russia respond
there was no
um specific mention as far as I'm aware
of a nuclear escalation uh of any kind
in that speech there has been before so
in in that way in terms of managing the
nuclear escalation risks which a lot of
us have been wondering and worrying
about let's um be honest it's it's uh it
it hasn't gone any further than what we
already were and that's a bit of a
relief I think my general Takeaway on on
this speech actually is that it was more
aimed at the global audience aimed at
the audience in the Middle East Putin
was speaking like he was uh addressing
the United Nations
um the audience is in the Middle East uh
South America
um China India and basically saying look
this is a clash of ideas in his view
um uh talked about sovereignty talked
about colonialism uh and and he's
appealing to basically everybody to try
to exclude that he pointed out the UK
and the US and and and their uh you know
basically aggression on him now you know
for for the global audience uh there's a
lot of Pop kettle black there you know
the the West has made mistakes does make
mistakes no one's perfect uh but so is
Russia right and
um yeah you know that that needs to be
pointed out too right and how do you
read the message to Kiev because he said
and I'm quoting him we call on Kiev to
immediately stop military actions and
return to the negotiation table I mean
how does this annexation and what we
just witnessed in the past 60 minutes or
so change the course of the war in
Ukraine do you think if any at all
well the
eventually is
clearly there was no threat like if you
don't do this we will do this I mean and
an ultimatum so you know
um and he did mention yes uh he called
on a ceasefire and they've been looking
for a ceasefire before but we know that
that Ukraine uh and its allies are well
Ukraine essentially is like we want to
keep fighting to take these areas back
and we believe there are
um and they have every right to
um and uh and and they've turned down
ceasefires before so in terms of you
know how does this this this actually
move on from here I think we'll have to
see how it plays out is is actually the
answer I would I would imagine that
Ukrainian forces are attacking as we
speak around Lee man again you know to
try to take and envelop those areas I
don't think that's going to change
um and so so uh in the short term at
least
um but we'll see we'll see how it plays
out on the ground
and as for sort of the western response
and the international community's
response we've heard the usual rhetoric
and you know the criticism and
condemnation and um countries in the
west describing this uh as illegal do
you think it'll make any difference at
all to to rush on what steps could they
take
did you say to Russia or yes do these
condemnations and criticism make any
difference at all
no I don't think so I don't think so I
think you will see them start to move
their mobilized troops in there as he
said they'll try and secure those areas
as best they can they don't hold
um all of those are blasts as we well
know so and they're contested uh as it
is in at least three of them anyway
um and and I don't see them actually
funny enough there was some scope
potentially of like a bargain between
okay we'll we'll withdraw from her son
and maybe zacharya but we'll keep
donetskansk
um now that they've had this signing in
ceremony as Putin explicitly said I
think that's more difficult for him
domestically much more difficult for him
to then actually come to some sort of
negotiator settlement even if the
ukrainians were willing to accept that
um so essentially yeah I think Russia
will try to to bolster the defenses
there as with their mobilized numbers
now coming on online uh and and the West
will keep that support uh for Ukraine
going in we saw I think yesterday eight
the announcement of 18 uh High Mars uh
rocket systems which will you know as
far as I'm aware that more than doubles
what was already the ukrainians have
going in there so
um I think that will continue
um but we're not out of that at least
this speech didn't raise the threat of
escalation even higher we're not out of
that yet all right thank you so much
Patrick burry for sticking around we
really appreciate it
pleasure thank you
now let's take a quick look at the areas
of Ukraine that the Kremlin now claims
as part of Russia it's about 15 percent
of Ukraine's territory but it's
important to note that under
international law it's illegal to hold
referendums during conflict and where
people under under threats and the U.N
Secretary General says the annexations
have no legal value and must not be
accepted we have Royal challenged
standing by for us in Kiev with the
reaction from there but first let's go
to Muhammad Val in Moscow so there it is
the signing ceremony happened Muhammad
tell us how this is all playing out in
Moscow where you are and what actually
happens next
yes that in ic uh people in the streets
carrying and waving Russian flags and
that Applause that you have seen during
this speech by President Vladimir Putin
so as he was also as he was addressing
the world as the analyst said he was
also basically and essentially
addressing Russians and telling them
that this is a move to redress the
wrongs of the past the history of Russia
he reiterated Russia is a great
civilization Russia is a great nation to
remind the Russians that they have to
fight for this greatness they have to
fight for this history he evoked some of
the ancient leaders or previous leaders
of the Russian Empire talking about the
children this is also for the
generations to come this is to protect
our children from the influence the
immoral influence coming from the West
he condemned what he called the the the
Western forcing of children to change
their sex for instance and that's a part
of a long a long condemnation of
everything the West is doing in his view
hypocrisy in its relationships with
other countries
colonization slavery destruction of
other peoples the use of nuclear weapons
he said the U.S is the only country that
has used nuclear weapons twice
and here iterated the fact according to
him that what happened today this
integration of Russia with its with
those territories is compatible with the
international law according to the first
article of the charter of the United
Nations I don't understand I don't know
what he means with that I think he means
that every people have the right to
decide their own destiny and their own
future so it's a speech but according to
Russians here is a speech of
mobilization he also congratulated those
who have participated in the
mobilization and he talked about the
need for every Russian to contribute and
to participate in the defense of the
national territory okay thank you so
much Muhammad Val is reporting for us
from Moscow over to Keith now we bring
in Rory chowns and Rory the president of
Russia Putin said that Kiev should
respect the will on the of the people
and he also called on Kiev to
immediately start military actions and
return to the negotiating table how is
this law likely to go down where you are
and what sort of response has there been
to this annexation
well I mean there was something I
noticed very strongly in listening to
Putin's speak there and I think it will
be noticed very strongly in Ukraine as
well and that is how little Putin in
that long speech actually spoke about
Ukraine at all uh you know essentially
he he doesn't really feel that Ukraine
is that relevant uh in this conflict he
doesn't see the Russia Ukraine war as a
war of peers he sees Ukraine essentially
as a puppet as a tool of Western
Ambitions uh he doesn't see that this is
a country really with its own agency
autonomy or sovereignty and that is
something that has chimed you know it
chimes with how ukrainians feel again
about the kremlin's attitude to them
Kremlin chauvinism they don't think that
the Kremlin respects Ukraine as an
independent country Putin has a view
that is essentially revanchist you know
he's he's talking about great historical
Russia he's harking back to the leaders
of Russia in the past like Catherine the
Great suvarov and saying that you know
the you the USSR when it collapsed was a
catastrophe that it destroyed a great
country the 90s were chaos for Russia
where Russia has taken advantage of by
the west and now Russia is renewing
itself and asserting its greatness uh
once again
he has called on the ukrainians to come
to the negotiating table uh but says
that these newly annexed parts of uh
well what Russia were Ukraine are
non-negotiable that of course is not
going to wash here in Kiev effectively
it doesn't make much difference to
what's Kiev is intending to do next
which is what it's been doing all along
since Russia invaded fight off the
Russian invasion and restore the
territories to Ukraine that Russia has
taken off them yes Russia eluded Putin
alluded to nuclear weapons he didn't
talk about a direct threat that he was
going to use them but he said that
Russia would use all the means of its
disposal or could use all the domains
that at its disposal to defend these
newly annexed territories but as our
guest Patrick was saying a little
earlier this doesn't actually change the
dial on the nuclear temperature it
doesn't increase it but it doesn't
decrease it that much either okay Rory
thank you so much Rory challenge
reporting from Kiev let's not bring in
Vladimir sotnikov he's an independent
political scientist who specializes in
Russia's Foreign Affairs he's joining us
from Moscow welcome to Al Jazeera just
give me your initial thoughts on what
stood out for you uh over the past thank
you very much when Putin was speaking
and during the signing ceremony
thank you very much first of all uh for
having me in your somehow a historic
program so I would like to speak uh
first of all that this is quite a
historic moment for for probably for
this civilization at least for the
Russian civilization but also the
Western Elites should take it very
seriously this is a sort of to my mind a
programming speech by President Vladimir
Putin because uh to some extent I think
that it will determine the cost of
relationship with the Western World for
years to come so this is a quite a new
Epoch actually which is which was
appearing has been appearing since
February what do you mean by that when
you say it will determine the
relationship because the fact that this
annexation is in fact not
internationally recognized describe the
referendums being described as a sham by
many countries
how does this play out in Russia and how
how is it actually going to affect
relations between the west and Moscow
uh let me disagree with you they
actually disagree uh in principle this
is not an annexation this is uh the will
of the people you know the the will of
the people in Donetsk and the lugansk
regions uh they this is the will of the
people so they they they said that they
are going to join Russia so that that is
that is actually not annexation because
this decision was actually preparing
long ago even from 2014 and should be
done in 2014. so as regards to the
relationship with the West uh first of
all uh my uh point was that uh the
deterioration uh the uh of the
relationship between uh Russia and the
the Western Powers
now is taking a new turn and and what
I'm talking about the new park that
means that for for for for years to come
uh this relationship will be will be
deteriorated there will be will be not
uh not determined like right
okay okay I'm afraid we'll have to leave
it there but we thank you so much for
joining us from Moscow thanks very much
thank you thank you thank you very much
thank you take care let's get U.S
reaction uh with our White House
correspondent Kimberly